Google Cloud updates for the fourth year
in a row Google has been named a leader
in the Gartner magic quadrant for cloud
AI developer Services learn more about
all the cool stuff we've been doing and
our commitment to responsible AI
principles on the blog for eight years
Google Cloud's devops research and
assessment team has published the
accelerate state of devops Report with
input from over 33 000 professionals
worldwide this annual report is an
independent view into how organizations
can drive better performance of their
devops practices and you can participate
and it's easy just take this year's
survey before the end of June it'll only
take you about 15 minutes check out the
links below for everything we covered on
this week's